[Music]
foreign
[Music]
can choose to power his way to the
screen slowly emerge in a Sinister
manner or simply walk towards the
protagonist carrying an aura that
quickly raises the stakes anything to
make that huge entrance that snaps into
a cliffhanger or turns the stakes up in
a snap of a finger so for today we're
going to be looking at villains who made
their mark on various kinds of memorable
entrances or introductions in anime
[Music]
the Colossal Titans entrance is up there
and we're going to be starting out with
this big entry
Attack on Titan really wasted no time in
going for it right the already cool
premise becomes even more engaging in
practice once you get to see how the
Colossal Titan got introduced amidst the
narration audiences were treated to an
astounding Testament to the crisis that
we've only felt or heard of when the
Colossal Titan makes its appearance it
does so not with a bang but with the
whole atmosphere created by its mere
presence as well as the ominous presence
it exudes just by standing making this
one of the stronger villain entrances
slash debuts off the top of my head
there's no loud shouting there's no
over-the-top reactions just plain
unadulterated fear something you'd
expect from Humanity when faced with a
larger than life threat one that
threatens the very foundations of their
very existence it's an entrance that
makes the threat feel very real and I
think it's one of the best ones out
there thanks to how much it helped push
the premise and the mood that the series
was going for
foreign
we've got a lot more legendary villain
entrances to come but how about taking a
bit of a detour to the realm of Heroes
after all the king of the dynamic
entrances Bar None is Scythe armor and
you can experience the magic with this
new game and the sponsors of this video
one punch man the strongest one punch
man needs no introduction to most of you
but did you know that it has this
extremely fun turn-based RPG on mobile
my favorite part about one punch man the
strongest is that it's an officially
licensed game so you know what that
means don't you it means you get to
experience the anime and all the cool
moments that come with it in the most
authentic manner possible complete with
visuals cut scenes voice acting and such
the character designs also look so
awesome and accurate and it makes it
even more tempting to collect them all
to bring them to the various modes that
the game provides with over 60 heroes
and villains available for recruiting
you have your hands full building your
perfect team so now is the best time to
get started on this game because with
over a million pre-registrations the
game's going all out in its celebratory
freebies get items such as old Hangar
Avatar aesthetic frames and my favorite
of them all free Rolls by just logging
in for seven days you can also get new
characters and even more free draws one
punch man the strongest is now available
on both Android and iOS you can download
the game by following the link or
scanning the QR code and don't forget to
input the promo code too it will help
the channel and the game immensely and
you get to fight alongside saithama as
the world's fastest rising hero sounds
like a win-win right but how about
something a little bit louder now
something more boisterous for the next
entry here's grimjao with his debut
foreign
[Music]
you can immediately tell how different
Attack on Titan and bleach are in terms
of atmosphere and genre execution when
you compare these two debuts there are
many great debuts for enemies in Bleach
but this is one that struck me hard when
I was a young team getting into anime
rookia had just finished impressing
everyone when this new entry introducing
himself as the sixth the spider appears
as the two protagonists look on in
horror citing his insane spiritual
pressure so how does grimjao make his
grand entrance by one shotting rookie
out of nowhere of course like the
Colossal Titan the anime tries to dial
up the threat of this new character by
appealing to the senses the shaking the
whole ominous air surrounding this new
character people talking about how
powerful this guy really is the
difference is that grimja wastes no time
showing off his prowess and getting
Ichigo to fight and backing up all those
claims by overwhelming the main
character compared to our first entry
where humanity is powerless against the
threats of nature Ichigo gets a chance
to fight this new threat as an equal
only to find himself getting his ass
kicked thoroughly though quite a good
intro production to someone who would
remain ichigo's biggest rival throughout
the ark right
since we're on the topical of loud
magical Samurai with powers how about
transitioning to sengoku basara and
hiroshi's first appearance
[Music]
has long been a stock character of sorts
in Japanese media next to Nobunaga
himself who better to portray them one
of his finest allies and mightiest
generals the hideyoshi's in anime and
video games come in different flavors
but in terms of sheer power and Dread
none evoked that feeling more than the
sengoku basana 2 form it's got the gruff
look and the spoken hype down pat but
how does he prove he's one of the most
badass portrayals of this historical
character how about staying unfazed in
the face of a reign of arrows before
standing there and casually sending
everything back at your attackers yeah
that will teach these enemies the
meaning of fear right and you want to
know what the catch is Hiroshi doesn't
even use any weapons none just pure
fists and brutes strength as he lays out
his enemies on mass and all it takes to
drive that message home is this Banger
of a first appearance
without you
we scale things down a bit with nui's
first appearance in killer kill
from bombastic entrances we reach nui's
introduction now how does this cute and
childish girl's first appearance
compared to all the badassery that we've
seen so far well in terms of pure
awesomeness there's nothing to write
home about at first except the super
casual one shot on Uzu establishing her
as a major threat then she walks towards
ryuko and nonchalantly reveals her role
in killing ryugo's father all that along
with the reveal of the scissor blade
done in a playful manner of course and
in a flick of a finger things suddenly
take on a complete 180 degree turn in
terms of stakes sengetsu goes berserk
now it's on while there's been an
entrance may not have the big ominous
atmosphere at first it's one that I'll
always remember because of how quickly
things turned from playful and comedic
to serious and high stakes and I think
the great villains can easily flip that
switch suddenly we have a major battle
on our hands
[Music]
now we look at the owls entrance in
Tokyo Ghoul
Tokyo Ghoul has really fallen off in
terms of reputation after the first
season it's such a sad fate comparable
to what happened to seven deadly sins
but don't let the haters fool you though
Tokyo Ghoul even passed its first season
still has a very of awesome moments and
scenes that completely run away with the
rule of call and this is one such
example don't tell me you won't be
scared out of your wit seeing owl
descend and appear from the smoke like
that and you're trapped there with him
nowhere to go nowhere to run just you
and this monster that put some RPG
bosses to shame and [ __ ] Fear Factor
we're left wondering what's next then
the screen just Fades to Black an Abrupt
end that keeps us on the edge of our
seeds wanting to know what's going to
happen next Al's already established as
a character before this so this doesn't
count as a debut but as far as villain
entrances And the emotions that make you
feel this is one extremely powerful
scene
[Music]
next up is Bond rude's Resurrection
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a featured made in Abyss quite several
times on my list but I don't think I've
ever featured the characters that much
that changes today and let's give a
round of applause to bond rude for this
great villain debut by the time this Arc
rolled around in anime form fondrued has
been sort of a mastermind behind the
scenes the master of body surfing
carries with him a rather unpleasant
reputation and he's been a thorn in the
sight of Our Heroes however those fears
created by his reputation and actions
get turned up to 11 when he emerges
again in his physical form and boy is it
scary to see the scene play out if we do
a bit of empathizing this moment toys
with us showing brush guards supposedly
heartwarming reaction only for a hand to
grab hold of said heart and twist it
around to establish that yeah this guy
here is legit one of the worst people in
fiction this moment toys with us and
gives us a huge amount of suspense as to
what's next for the character what more
can this guy who has no sense of good or
evil do what's important is that he's
back and the main characters are going
to be in for the fight of their lives
our Gaza makes an appearance here rather
out of nowhere like he did
[Music]
the whole Infinity trade movie or Arc
depending on which medium you watch this
on led us all to believe the animal was
the big one I mean this is the guy who
survived muzan's Purge of his
subordinates while carrying what
conceptually is very overpowered ability
then the good guys beat him in an epic
battle and it's time for the unwinding
right suddenly this new demon upper Moon
3 appears out of nowhere just right when
our heroes are at their most vulnerable
and it's a sudden climax just when you
thought it was all over agaza's entrance
for me excels so much due to its timing
and how much it shifted the tone of the
movie or episode It just fits so
perfectly with UFO table's art and sound
Direction the whole thing with argaza
appearing and only rengoku being in any
form ready to battle What followed was
one of the greatest fights in battle
shown in movie history and if you don't
want a more in-depth look at the fight
you can check out one of the other
videos on my channel which I'll be
linking above
foreign
characters in one piece and how does he
show it by defeating the supernovas of
course but don't let anyone tell you his
prowess came out of nowhere we've all
been warned when he made his entrance in
sarvodi there are a few things that are
bigger flexes than the Swagger field
where he entered the scene he gave zero
care in the world as he's getting shot
while easily dispatching everyone in
sight while he may not look the coolest
or the most intimidating amongst the
huge gallery of villains in one piece
gizuru lets his actions do the talking
in this scene one which features him
making quick work of Hawkins as well and
when Abu joined the party oh big mistake
few villains can enter the scene looking
so unfazed as if he's just toying with
all the poor fools in his sight and
kizaru does it with so much swag that he
quickly turned himself into one of the
most intimidating characters out there
and to think that Luffy and Gary gonna
have to face him eventually what a great
way to build up the hype
[Music]
and that wraps up our list eight of my
favorite and most memorable anime
villain entrances now I hope you had a
good time with this one it's been great
sharing these moments with you and I'll
see you next time oh and don't forget to
check out our sponsors game one punch
man the strongest links in the
description